[Music]
most netflix movies don't have a 200
million dollar budget but most netflix
movies aren't the gray man why has
netflix spent so much money on this
potential franchise here's everything
you need to know about the next big
movie from the directors of avengers
endgame
the grey man is a project that had been
in development hell since 2011 before it
found its home on netflix at one point
both brad pitt and charlize theron were
reportedly in talks to appear in the
film and it wasn't until early 2020 that
the movie solidified its cast and
directors the action film is based on
the book of the same name by mark graney
and follows a former cia operative on
the run in europe who's being hunted by
his former colleague on the red carpet
for spider-man no way home in december
2021 director joe russo revealed to
variety that the gray man would be
released in the summer of 2022. at the
time the director admitted the movie
still had a lot of vfx that needed to be
worked on which would consume a lot of
time in post-production
uh i think we'll probably you know lock
picture on that sometime in like
february in april netflix confirmed that
the gray man would be available for
streaming on july 22nd 2022 the official
trailer for the film revealed that the
movie will also be available to watch in
theaters with a limited release starting
on july 15th
while netflix has been pretty
tight-lipped regarding the grey man mark
granny's source novel gives us an
indication of the film's plot we won't
spoil the ending of that novel for you
though court gentry also known as cr6
also known as the grey man is a former
cia operative much like ethan hunt and
james bond six is probably the world's
best assassin with the agency
greenlighting his kills however six
uncovers some dirty secrets within the
cia and finds himself on the run from
lloyd hansen a former cia officer who is
now employed by a shady french
organization when the president of
nigeria calls for six's murder hansen
and his allies oblige in order to
maintain a good relationship for a
lucrative oil deal it's currently
unclear if netflix's adaptation will
strictly stick to the same plot as the
novel
it was first reported that joe and
anthony russo of marvel studios fame
were attached to direct the grey man in
2015 per deadline however at the time
the brothers were reportedly overwhelmed
with their phase 3 projects for the mcu
and they opted to write the script for
the grey men but not direct as the movie
languished in development for several
more years the russo brothers were able
to hop back aboard as directors
officially in 2020. joe russo also took
a screenplay credit alongside avengers
endgame writer stephen mcfeely and
christopher marcus in a conversation
with fandango joe russo amped up the
movie saying i feel like the gray man is
basically everything we learned over the
last decade pour it into one film in the
last 10 years the russos have directed
some of the biggest movies ever made
including the final two avengers flicks
captain america the winter soldier and
captain america civil war it seems
likely that the grey man won't be
anything less than stellar
in july 2020 deadline exclusively
revealed that ryan gosling had joined
the grey man to play the titular
protagonist this marks the first major
motion picture for gosling since 2018
when he played neil armstrong in first
man speaking to empire about the grey
man gosling revealed that he wouldn't be
opposed to making some sequels saying
what i liked about this character is
that he wants something that most of us
want which is just to be free his goals
aren't monetary it's not about treasure
it's not revenge he just wants to have
the right to sit on the couch and watch
netflix like the rest of us during the
interview gosling revealed that six has
a dry sense of humor that'll be evident
in every scene you must be loyal what
gave it away the white pants the trash
dash
he might be known for playing the hero
but the grey man sees chris evans step
into the villain's shoes as six's
biggest adversary lloyd hansen director
joe russo even revealed that evans had
indicated being ready to take some
serious risks in his career which led
him to being cast as the antagonist
speaking to dead of geek russo explained
so it seemed obvious to us that the
right move here would be to offer chris
the sociopath and not the hero evans has
also teased what to expect from his
character telling empire in may 2022
he's a train wreck of a human being that
guy can be anything in any scene because
all he wants is anarchy i didn't kill
anybody in december 2020 deadline
revealed anna de armas had joined the
gray man as ci agent danny miranda the
armistice character is someone who takes
their job at the agency very seriously
she'll work closely with six but the duo
will spend some time figuring out if
they can be allies according to danny's
official poster for the film the agent
is untraceable suggesting she might be
able to help six escape lloyd's capture
not much else is known as de armas's
character as dany does not exist in the
gray man novel it's possible her
character is an amalgamation of others
from the book or inspired by one
specific character but the cast and crew
are keeping quiet for now
one of the later additions to the grey
man was burgerton's scene stealer reggae
jean-page the actor plays denny
carmichael a character pulled straight
from the book speaking to l page
revealed there's a lot of shadow and
contrast to this character it's
something that i don't think people have
seen a lot of from me specifically
before which was great fun for me to
play with denny is the head of cia
clandestine services so we can expect a
lot of mystery and sketchiness
surrounding the character the film marks
the first project for paige since his
shocking bridgeton exit the grey man
will prove if he's got what it takes to
make it on the big screen
billy bob thornton plays court gentry's
handler donald fitzroy in the grey man
netflix revealed that fitzroy recruited
gentry to join the sierra program and
he's recently been replaced as director
as one of the only allies six has left
fitzroy is in just as much danger from
what we know from the greyman novel
fitzroy will be used by lloyd hansen and
his allies to lure in six filling out
the grey man cast are a lot of
recognizable names oscar nominee alfree
woodard plays margaret cahill an old
friend of gentries who might be his last
resort in finding help outside the law
jessica hendwick stars as susannah
brewer who works alongside reggae
jean-page's denny carmichael indian
actor danush will play aviksan a deadly
assassin who targets six for an unknown
reason
there were many takeaways from the first
trailer for the great man the film seems
to be reminiscent of many action
franchises such as mission impossible
and james bond it looks like the movie
will be fast-paced but there will be
comedic relief from ryan gosling and
chris evans who have a few face-to-face
moments in the trailer the trailer
suggests that lloyd catches up with six
at least twice in the film with a fist
fight breaking out between the pair we
can also expect a car chase or two along
with gunfights explosions and extensive
stunt work anna de armas's danny miranda
and goslings 6 appeared together in the
trailer and it looks as though their
characters have come to trust one
another lloyd is as sociopathic as we
expected appearing to have no issues
killing people and with his sights laser
focused on 6. billy bob thornton's
donald fitzroy also gives the impression
that six is impossible to kill and might
be impossible to outwit
netflix is making history with the gray
man which is the platform's biggest
movie ever deadline reported that the
movie had a 200 million dollar budget
from the jump which puts it ahead of
former title holder red notice initially
the gal gadot film reportedly had a
budget of 160 million dollars but
constant delays from the covet 19
pandemic jumped the price to around 200
million dollars
the record held by the grey men seems to
be based on its initial budget and not
from add-ons along the way plus 200
million dollars is a far cry from
netflix's other big-budget films like
the irishman which cost 159 million
dollars six underground which came in at
150 million dollars and outlaw king
which cost 120 million dollars according
to joe russo a huge budget was essential
in order to make the grey man as
spectacular as any action movie that
would be released exclusively in
theaters russo even teased to empire the
viewers will feel that 200 million
dollars during the film's immense action
sequences
it seems pretty likely that netflix will
be making another the grey man movie
that was always the plan from the jump
with joe russo telling deadline in july
2020 the idea is to create a franchise
and build out a whole universe with ryan
at the center of it we have all
committed to the first movie and that's
gotta be great to get us to the second
movie there's also plenty of content to
pull from as mark granny's the grey man
series currently stands at 11 books
anthony russo also feels confident about
moving forward with the grey man
franchise telling the wall street
journal the grey man has a large
ensemble a layered story that you are
only seeing the tip of the iceberg we
have a lot of ideas about where to take
it next the only thing that might deter
a sequel is if the film fails to draw an
audience however with the russo brothers
at the helm and chris evans and ryan
gosling leading the charge it seems
likely that the grey man will be a clear
success
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
new netflix movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]